hey this is presh talwalkar
a party has 100 people who are either
liars or truth-tellers
liars always lie
and truth-tellers always speak the truth
after the party is over
you ask each person
how many truth-tellers did you shake
hands with
each person gave a different answer
ranging from the numbers 0 to 99
the answers were the whole numbers from
0 to 99
how many liars were at the party
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
this logic problem seems impossible
because you do not know which people
shook hands with each other
however we can deduce from their answers
how many people at the party were
truth-tellers and how many people are
liars
we'll start by labeling each person
we'll say person 99 is the one who
replied to have shaken hands with 99
truth tellers
similarly person 98 said to have shaken
hands with 98 truth tellers
we'll continue this labeling all the way
down to person zero who shook hands with
zero truth tellers
let's consider first person 99
imagine person 99 was a truth teller
what could we deduce from that
if person 99 is a truth teller
that would mean person 99 must have
shaken hands with everyone else all
other 99 people at the party
and because that person said they shook
hands with 99 truth tellers that means
everyone else at the party must also be
a truth teller
but person 99 would have then also shook
hands with person zero
who is said to have shaken hands with
zero truth tellers
how can person zero have shaken hands
with zero truth tellers and be a truth
teller
one possibility is that 99 and 0 did not
shake hands
this would mean person 99 is a liar
or
person 0 shook hands only with liars
which would also mean person 99 is a
liar
it's not logically possible for person
99 to be a truth teller
therefore person 99 must be a liar
we will identify person 99 accordingly
now that we know person 99 is a liar
what else can we figure out
let's look at person 98.
if person 98 is a truth teller that
would mean person 98 shook hands with
persons 0 to 97
and all of those people must be truth
tellers
we can make this deduction because we
know 99 is a liar if you exclude person
99
we're left with person 0 to 97 which are
only 98 people
so the only way person 98 could be a
truth teller and shake hands with 98
people is that person 98 would have
shaken hands with persons 0 to 97 who
must all be truth tellers
but this would mean person 98 also shook
hands with person 0
who is said to have shaken hands with
zero true tellers
once again this is possible only if 98
and 0 did not shake hands which would
make person 98 a liar
or
person 0 shook hands only with liars
which would once again mean person 98 is
a liar
in either possibility
we can conclude person 98 is not a truth
teller and therefore person 98 must be a
liar
we will label person 98 accordingly
now we can continue this process
we can inductively then prove that
persons 97
96 and so on all the way down to person
one must all be liars
we'll label each person accordingly
what about person zero
we've already figured out that persons
one to person 99 is a liar
everyone else at the party is a liar
therefore person zero necessarily shake
hands with only liars there are zero
truth tellers that person zero can shake
hands with
this means person zero is telling the
truth and is therefore a truth teller
so the answer to this problem
is that there are 99 liars persons 1 to
99 and exactly one truth teller which is
person zero
did you figure out this problem
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description